[موسيقى]
مرحبًا يا رفاق ، إنها فتاتك ليزا لويس ، أنا
مؤثر على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وخبيرة
في اللياقة البدنية الآن لا أستطيع الوصول إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية في الوقت الحالي.
لن تحتاج إلى أي معدات ، فهل
أنتم مستعدون ،
كل الرجال المناسبين ، سأضعكم
في ثلاث
دوائر منفصلة لكل
منها تركيز مختلف ،
ستركز الدائرة الأولى على
الدائرة النصف ثانية السفلية التي ستركز
على  النصف العلوي
والثالث والأخير ، سنركز على
الجذع ، القلب
، دائرة القيمة المطلقة
رقم واحد للقلب السفلي ،
سنبدأ هنا ،
أريدك أن تكون على سجادتك
لمحطتك ، سنقوم بعمل
اندفاع عكسي
قفزة القرفصاء بالاندفاع مرة أخرى
اندفع عكسي القرفصاء والاندفاع العكسي واقفز
[موسيقى]
سنحصل على وضعين هنا
سنقوم بالاندفاع الجانبي
مباشرة إلى الخلف إلى ذلك
الاندفاع الجانبي
لذا كرر هنا
شكل مستقيم لطيف للخلف لطيف  ومسطحة وتجد إيقاعًا لطيفًا
جيدًا  بعد 10 ممثلين هنا ،
ستقوم بالتبديل ، والآن سيكون
الجانب الآخر
يتحرك على طول الدائرة الثانية حيث
سنركز على
كل شيء من الوركين إلى أعلى أولاً ،
أريدك أن تنزل على الأرض
هذا هو  تمرين ضغط كلاسيكي كلاسيكي
ولكننا سنقوم في الواقع بإطلاق يدك ،
لذا ستحملك مسؤولية أكبر
في النزول إلى الأرض قدر
الإمكان بدلاً من دفع نفسك
للأعلى من الحركة الأرضية
رقم 2 في الجزء العلوي من الجسم
يتطلب التمرين منا البقاء على الأرض ،
وسنكون
على أيدينا وعلى أصابع قدمنا ، وهذا ما
سميه وض
الوحش الجانبي ، لذا مر
أخرى من هنا ، سوف تت
كد من أن كتفيك مكدسة فو
معصميك  وبعد ذلك
ستنتقل بلطف وتتحكم
في جانب واحد من سجادتك ثم تعود إلى
وضع البداية
وتكرر
[موسيقى]
أخيرًا وآخر حلبة يا رفاق
سننتقل إلى الأمام سأجعلك
تجلس  على سجادتك الآن مع هذا
الشخص الأول
ستكون e عبارة عن أزمة عكسية لدينا
ثلاث
نقاط من الضربات بمعنى أننا نعكس الأزمة ،
سنرسل أقدامنا في اتجاه مختلف
في ثلاثة اتجاهات مختلفة بحيث
تكون يداك المزروعتان خلف مؤخرتك
تمتد الركبتان للخارج ، دعونا نقود ركبنا في
الرأس إلى اليسار ، نعود إلى الوسط ،
ثم الجانب الآخر جيدًا
يضرب حقًا جميع نقاط جوهر
[الموسيقى] ،
كل اللاعبين المناسبين أخيرًا ونهائيًا سننزل
على
الأرض '  سنقوم بتنوع متسلق الجبال لدينا ،
لكننا سنتوقف مؤقتًا
بثلاث مرات ،
دعني أوضح
أنك ستكون الآن في مستوى عالٍ من اللوح الخشبي ،
سنقوم
برسم ركبنا إلى صدرنا بهذه الطريقة
وجبل  متسلق
ولكن في كل ثالث عدد ، سنقوم
بالانسحاب قليلاً قبل أن نذهب مرة أخرى
هنا نذهب لآخر مرة ،
كل الرجال الذين يعملون جيداً
يستمعون لمزيد من النصائح ونصائح اللياقة البدنية ، تابعوني
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، يمكنك أن
تجدني على المقبض ،
اتبع ليزا على الإنستغرام  الفيسبوك
وتويت  r وتذكر دعونا نتجنب كل
الأعذار
التي ستمنعنا من الشعور بالسعادة
والصحة
والنشاط أثناء السير على الطريق حتى
المرة القادمة